اتهم ملك ومؤسس ميليشيا فاجنر الروسيه
الخاصه
اتهم وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان الروسيين
بمحاوله تدمير مجموعته وبحرمان مقاتلها في
اوكرانيا من الذخيره وهو ما وصفه بانه
بمثابه خيانه عظمى
غداه رساله اتهم فيها مؤسس فاغنر مسؤولين
لم يسميهم بالخيانه وبالعمل مع الاعداء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولد في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله توجيه قائد ميليشيا
باجنر اتهامات علنيه بهذه الخطوره
لمسؤولين في مستوى وزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان الروسيين ورميهما بالخيانه العظمى
والعمل مع الاعداب ثم ما الاهميه التي
يكتسبها توقيت هذه الاتهامات المتزامنه مع
معارك مفصليه يخوضها مقاتل فاجنر حول
باخموت وما تعاهدات بوتين بالمضي قدما في
حرب اوكرانيا بالتزامن مع ذكرى مرور عام
على انطلاقها ثم ما هي التاثيرات المحتمله
للخلاف بين فاجنر والقياده العسكريه في
روسيا على سير الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا
وعلى مستقبل دور هذه المجموعه في اوكرانيا
وخارجها
[موسيقى]
بعد يوم من اتهام لم يحدد فيه اسماء
المتهمين وجه مؤسس ميليشيا فاجنر
اتهاما صريحا لوزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان
الروسيين بمحاوله تدمير باجنر وبحرمان
مقاتليها في اوكرانيا من الذخيره وهو ما
اعتبره بمثابه خيانه العظمى للبلاد ولمح
مؤسس ميليشيا فاجنر الى مسؤوليه المسؤولين
الرفيعين في هرم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه عما
سماه الخسائر المتزايده في صفوف مقاتل
فاجنر والمجموعات الاخرى في المعارك حول
بخموت واضاف مؤسس ميليشيا فاجنر ان موقف
وزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان من مجموعته
مرده العداء الشخصي له وانه طلب منه
الاعتذار طلب الاعتذار والاذعان من اجل
توفير الذخيره لمقاتله في اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من عمان اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
وسيلتحق بنا لاحقا ايضا في هذه الحلقه من
الدوحه الدكتور عمر عاشور استاذ الدراسات
الامنيه والعسكريه اهلا بك حضره اللواء
فايز الدويري لنبدا بمكان يقال بشكل غير
رسمي عن وجود خلاف بين فاقنر وبين المؤسسه
العسكريه الروسيه ها هو هذا اليوم يتفجر
بشكل علني وبالاسماء ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
يعني في كافه الحروب
للنصر اب واحد
وللهزيمه اباء عده لهذا السبب في حال حدوث
النصر او سلوك طريق النصر كما يعتقد
القاده كل قائد يحاول ان يجعل
الانجازات هي من ضمن قدراته وتوجيهاته
وطريقه ادارته للمعركه
فبالتالي هذه الخلافات بدات منذ منذ
بدايات معركه سوليدار ولكن كما اشرت لم
تكن تظهر للعالم طبعا وراها جمله من
العوامل كما قلت لك الكل يحاول ان يدعي
انه السبب الرئيسي للنصر ولكن هناك اسباب
شخصيه اخرى لان هناك بعض التقارير اشارت
الى ان قائد مجموعه فاجنر لديه
اطماع وطموح شخصي ان يكون وزيرا للدفاع
وخاصه هناك نقطه يرتكز عليها ان معظم دول
العالم وزراء الدفاع اصلا مدنيين لكن في
الحال الروسيه كما في كثير من دول اخرى
ياتي من خلفيه عسكريه وبالتالي هو لا يمثل
خلفيه عسكريه يعتد بها ولكن بالمقابل وزير
الدفاع الحالي لم ياتي من خلفيه عسكريه
يعتد بها هو مهندس وبالتالي عين وزيرا
للدفاع يحمل رتبه جنرال فري ستار جنرال
وبالتالي ما يمنع
قائد مجموعه ان يكون البديل خاصه وان قوات
فاجنر استطاعت ان تنجز ما عجزت عنه القوات
النظاميه وخير مثال على ذلك
اذا بدانا بها من ايام
2014 او 2012-2014 ومن ثم شبه جزيره القرم
ودخولا
العمليه الخاصه عندما توقفت القوات الجيش
الروسي امام سوليدار البلده الصغيره
وبالتالي دفع بقوات فاجنر واستطاعت ان
تنجز
في عجاله المعركه الحاليه هي هجوم من
ثلاثه اتجاهات الجهه الجهه الشرقيه الجهه
الجنوبيه والجنوبيه الغربيه
فاقنر تعمل في الواجهه الشماليه وهي التي
تحقق الانجاز في مع القوات الروسيه لا
تزال متعثره فتم نقل جزء من فاجنر الى
الجهه الجنوبي الغربي اذا هذه هي الحاله
المقاطعه
الدكتور عمر عاشور استاذ الدراسات الامنيه
والعسكريه دكتور عمر هل عندما نتكلم عن
هذا الخلاف الذي طفى الى السطح بهذه
الاتهامات المباشره وبالاسماء وتطال اعلى
هرم المؤسسه العسكريه الروسيه هل نحن امام
خلاف بين
مؤسستين
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وبين فاجنر كشركه ام
خلاف شخصي بين رئيس هذه الشركه وبين وزير
الدفاع وقائد الاركان
اكثر تعقيدا يعني به هذا البعد بعد الخلاف
الشخصي لكن الخلاف بين النقل عناصر في
وزاره الدفاع يتشابله وزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان وفجر قديم يعني 2018 في خشام في
سوريا حين واجه القوات الامريكيه تركتهم
القياده العسكريه الروسيه يواجهوا مصيرهم
وسحقوا من الجو فليست المره الاولى وفيها
في اثناء هذه الحرب الاثني عشر شهرا
الماضيه تقريبا
ومعه عناصر اخرى من فاجنر لم يتوقفوا عن
مهاجمه قاده محددين قاده مناطق مناطق
عسكريه خاصه المنطقه الوسطى والمنطقه
الغربيه
وايضا واحيانا المنطقه الشرقيه الوحيد
الذي لم ينتقد بشكل كبير هو سيرا القائد
السابق قبل تعيين جراثيم اوف
رؤيا ذلك على انه يعني محاوله كما تفضل
لواء فايز انه ليحل
او حتى شويه وزير الدفاع او رئيس الاركان
في هذا الاطار كان هناك البعد طموح
السياسي الذي كان الذي اشعل الموقف اكثر
واكثر هو الفتره السابقه الفتره السابقه
ما حدث انه حدث التراجعات من القوات
النظاميه في خرسان كان تراجع منظم الى حد
ما ولكنه تراجع خلف خطوط دفاعيه اقوى خلف
النهر
وفي هار كيف كان انهيار انهيار تامه حصل
في هجوم مضاد اوكراني بارع انتهى بتقدم
الاوكراني والعوده الى شمال لوهانسك مره
ثانيه من الذي كان يتقدم كان القوات فاجنر
كانت يعني هي تتقدم ولكن بمساعده قوات
اخرى كان لديها حشد هائل سمح وهذه السلطه
السياسيه القانونيه
اللي هو رئيس جماعه الذي لا يمتلك اي منصب
سياسي رسمي لا هو قاضي ولا هو رئيس محكمه
ولا غيره ويدخل الى السجون
يحشد اكثر من 30 الى 35 الف وقعوا على
عقود مع عقود بمده سته اشهر للخدمه في
اوكرانيا
فيرسلها هؤلاء المدربين بشكل يعني بسيط
للغايه ويحشدهم في امام القوات الاوكرانيه
نتائج نعم نعم يحقق نتائج لانه الان لديك
مجموعه شركه امنيه بين اقواس تدير يعني
على الاقل نصف جبهه بقوه خمسه فرق نظاميه
لان تعددها حوالي 50 الف يعني 35 الف من
المدنيين سابقا 5,000 كانوا عندها من قبل
والعشره الاف المحترفين
فهذه القوه قوه هائله فهي يعني مشابهه جدا
للموجات البشريه
تحدث تثبيت للقوات الاوكرانيه
ويقتل عوامل دكتور عمر ولكن يدخل ايضا
عليها القوات النظاميه الاوكرانيه هي الذي
يحدث الالتفافات والمناورات الهجوميه وحتى
التقدم في سوليدار كانت تفعل قوات
يا سيد يعني في البدايه هذه الشركه لا
شركه لها خصوصيه يعني علينا ان نعود الى
اكثر من عقد من الزمن حتى نجيب على هذا
السؤال لماذا هذه الشركه هي عابره للحدود
هذه الشركه في بعض التقارير التي لم نتحقق
منها عملت في 30 دوله ولكن المؤكد
عشر دول وبالتالي بدءا من سوريا الى مالي
الى مدغشقر الى افريقيا الوسطى الى
فنزويلا الى موزمبيق الى السودان الى
ليبيا وبالتالي هذه لم تكن تذهب فقط من
خلال قائد قوات فاجنر ينسب الشركات
الامنيه الخاصه كما يطلق عليها تستخدم
خارج الحدود بعطر محدده تعميم حمايه
لشخصيه معينه يعني بعض كثير من زعامات
العالم وحتى زعمات عربيه حرص الشخصي هو من
الشركات الام وليس من ابناء جلدته ولن
ادخل في اسماء ماذا عن دورها في اوكرانيا
بوفيه تذهب
ساجيبك يعني انا فقط في عجاله عندما تذهب
الى افريقيا تذهب وهي تحمل مشروع روسي اذا
ذهابها مغطى سياسيا من قبل القياده
السياسيه وامنيا وعسكريا من قبل
الاستخبارات اذا لم تعد شركه بمفهوم شركه
هي اصبحت اداء للقياده السياسيه
وللاستخبارات الروسيه وهذا ما دفعها او
بالدخول في اوكرانيا دخلته اوكرانيا حققت
انجازات لماذا السؤال لماذا اخفق الجيش
الروسي ولماذا نجحت فاقنر هناك مجموعه من
العوامل لكن اهمها ضعف الاداء الفردي
واداء القاده حتى مستوى قائد الفرقه فيما
بالمقابل كما ذكر الدكتور احذروا من
السجون تم انتقائهم خلفيات اجراميه سواء
بالقتل بالاغتصاب بالمخدرات مقابل سته
شهور يخدم راس حربه ويتم الغاء الحكم عنه
اذا هو اكثر صرامه واكثر وانضباطا وتوكل
له المهام القذره فاستطاع ان يحقق ما عجز
عنه الاخرين هذه الانجازات تجعل من قائد
مجموعه
ان ينمي طموحاته السياسيه
والمراكز المستقبليه له هل سيكون مدير
الاستخبارات هل سيكون مكان وزير الدفاع
استبعد ان يكون مكانتك
الخلفيه العسكريه
هل فكر السيد بريكوجين قبل ان يطلق عليه
تصريحات بشكل علني ويوجه الاتهامات ايضا
بالاسماء لهؤلاء القاده وزير الدفاع وقائد
الاركان وانا اسال الدكتور عمر عاشور
عندما نكون في دوله بحجم روسيا يقودها رجل
يعني سيد الجميع ومع ذلك يعني يظهر او
يخرج السيد
ويعطي هذه التصريحات الحساسه والخطيره في
توقيت حساس هل معنى ذلك بان لم يستطع
الرئيس بوتين حل هذه المشاكل اما تفسير
ذلك
لا هو يجب ان ينظر اليها انه يعني
لا يوجد يسيطر على كل شيء بشكل بشكل يعني
على المستوى المايكرو يعني فمن ناحيه هو
كان الصراحه حقيقي ويبدو انه كان يستخدمهم
ضد بعض يعني يرى من يخدمه اكثر ولكن يبدو
لي ان حتى في هذا الاطار يخسر المعركه
يخسر المعركه لعده اسباب هو يعني البعض
وان كانت غير مثبت يقول ان علاقته
بالاساسيه هي بتجي ار يو بالاستقباط
العسكريه الروسيه والان لا تصله القذائف
فهو يشتكي لان القاده افلاط نحن نعرف من
الحاله الليبيه ان القذائف كانت تصله عبر
عبر الجياريو ويوجد مهما يعني يوفق هذا
هذا الموضوع في هذه الحاله هو يشتكي ان
قذائف لا تصله وكان يطمح في حليفه الذي
كان ربما يقال انه لم يحقق حقيقه القائد
الرابع للعمليه في اوكرانيا انه لم يحقق
صحيح تقدم هجومي كبير ولكن على الاقل حافظ
دفاعات وحافظ على الارض وبدا حمله حمله
جويه هجوميه ارهقت الاوكرانيين حليف هذا
ازيح واعيد قائد العمليه السبب في في
الخسائر الاوليه قائد العمليه الاول اللي
هو رئيس الاركان اللي هو
صار الان هو قائد العمليه وازيح صرافه وهو
ايضا يضغط عليه بهذه الطريقه فيبدو انه
يخسر المعركه تدريجيا امام امام
نموذج استراتيجيا صعب ما يجري في باك موت
النقطه ان ما يقال ان هذا الشخص كلفنا
خمسه اضعاف الخسائر وباخد كانت من البدايه
من فبراير هو تولى يعني تصدر المشهد في
باخد منه نوفمبر نحن الان في فبراير الاخر
في فبراير 23 فحوالي اربعه او خمسه اشهر
تقريبا ما هو التقدم الذي احرزه في بخموت
التقدم بسيط ولكن في مقابل خمسه اضعاف
الخسائر التي خسرتها الجيش الروسي فما
يقال غالبا هذا يعني فرضيه ما يقلب بوتين
هذا الشخص لم يحقق شيء صحيح اخذ سوليدار
ولكن هذا الاخذ مشترك هذا نحن وهو في باقي
مت لم يحقق كثير ولكن خسرنا خمسه اضعاف
الخسائر صحيح من السجناء اغلبيتهم ولك
خساره رخيصه لن تتحرك مثل ما حدث في حرب
الشيشان الاولى امهاتهم لن تتحرك وتدق على
ابواب وتقول له اعيدوا اولادنا
فهؤلاء يعني ولكنه لم يحقق حقيقه شيء
والذي فعل فعلا المناوره الهجوميه سواء في
شمال في الصيف الماضي في في تشكيك او
حاليا كانوا كانوا قوات كانوا الفائده كان
قوات محموله جوا استطاعت ان تحقق هذه
التقدمات وبالتالي لماذا هذا الشخص يعني
يزعجنا بهذه الطريقه فاعيد الرئيس الاركان
اللي هو كان قائد العمليه عمليا يعني كان
قائد العمليه في فبراير 22 الان اعيد مره
اخرى
ويبدو ان يشعر بالضغط عليه فيشتكي علنا
يعني هل هذه الشكوى علنا ستجعل يمدونه
بالقذائف هو الكل يعاني من الشلهنجر من
جوع الذخيره يعني الاوكران والقوات
النظاميه الروسيه والقوات الغير نظاميه
الروسيه لا يوجد قذائف تتحمل يعني معدلات
القذائف المدفعيه المتبادله من حوالى
اليوم للجانب الروسي وخمسه الاف اليوم
للجان
الدويري ايا كانت الخلفيات التي تدفع الى
هذا التراشق بين الطرفين خاصه من تصريحات
رئيس شركه فاجنر ماذا عن الجندي الروسي
العادي في قوات الجيش الروسي او
المنظر تحت هذه الشركه فاجنر تاثير هذه
التصريحات في حرب هي الان عالميه فعلا
ولكنها على ارض اوكرانيا
يا سيدي فيما يتعلق بجماعه فاجنر وقعوا
على عقود
تتضمن مجموعه من البنود
تحدد الراتب
تحدد تعويض في حال الاصابه وتحدد تعويض في
حال الوفاه وعليه ان يعمل كراس حربه في
الاعمال الخطره والاعمال القذره اذا هو
لا يستطيع ان يناقش لا يستطيع ان يرفض
وهذا ما وقع عليه في حال الجيش الروسي
النظامي نعود الى العقيده القتاليه
العقيده القتاليه سواء في الجيش السوفيتي
العقل الجيش الاحمر او في الجيش الروسي
الذي اجرى بعض التعديلات على العقيده بقي
لديهم اهم بند في هذه العقيده
تحقيق الهدف دون النظر الى الخسائر
البشريه والماديه اذا القائد الروسي عندما
يضع امام عينيه او نصب عينيه هدفا ما من
ضمن الخطه عليه ان يحقق هذا الهدف بغض
النظر عن الخسائر بمعنى اخر لا يوجد اهميه
وقيمه لحياه الجندي وساثبت لك ذلك في
معركه باخموت الحاليه الجيش الروسي يعتمد
نظام ما يطلق عليه الموجات المتلاحقه
الموجات البشري المتتاليه وبالتالي قد
تحصد الموجه الاولى والثاني والثالثه حتى
يحققوا تقدم للسيطره على تل صغير تعبويا
اذا في كلا هذا تراشق
في المؤسستين
لا يا سيدي بالنسبه للرتب بالنسبه للرتب
تغيير ثمن قاده منذ بدء المعركه حتى
اللحظه التي اتحدث بها هو
امر يعطي انطباع واضح ان الكفاءات في
الجيش الروسي على مستوى الجنرالات كفاءات
متدنيه قد لا يعجب كلامي الكثيرين ولكن ان
تغير ثمن قادم خلال اقل من تسعه اشهر هذا
يعني ان مستوى القاده لا ينسجم وحجم
المهام المنكر لهم وبالتالي اعتقد ان في
نظام كنظام الجيش الروسي حتى اي جنرال لا
يستطيع ان يبدي رايه بالجراه الكامله امام
وزير الدفاع او رئيس الاركان لان الاجراء
فورا عزله من منصبه وهذا يختلف عن الجيوش
الاخرى وهذا ايضا يحيلنا مره اخرى الدكتور
عمر اذا ما عدنا سنه الى الوراء ويتم الان
مرور سنه على بدايه العاميه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا اكثر من قائد تم
تعيينه لقياده العمليات في اوكرانيا وتم
عزله ثم ياتي هذا التراشق قلت بان الرئيس
بوتين ربما قد يكون يستفيد من هذه
الحساسيه بين الجهتين ولكن ما مدى تاثير
هذا الخلاف على ما يجري على الارض
تاثيرها على ما يجري على الارض انا اظن ان
يكون هناك تاثير كبير فيما يجعل الارض
يعني هي المعنويات كانت منخفضه للغايه من
البدايه تغير القاده الان نحن هذا هو
القائد الخامس الذي عين مرتين في البدايه
وفي النهايه وبين وبين تعيين الاول
وتعيينه الثاني اربعه قاده اخرين بالاضافه
الى بالاضافه لقاده الميليشيات يعني
لانه يستقلون ايضا الى شيء يعني هم تابعون
للحرس الحرس الوطني الروسي روزاليا ولكنهم
تقريبا بياخذوا اوامرهم ليس من زلطوف ولكن
من الرئيس الشيشاني من قديروف فهؤلاء كلهم
يعني زعماء حرب والى حد ما مستقلون
وبالتالي كل كل منهم له اهدافه الخاصه
الان المشكله الكبرى ان ان يعني نحن الان
في الهجوم الربيع الذي بدا في الشتاء هجوم
الربيع الذي بدا في الشتاء في حوالي سته
خمسه او سته محاور من جنوبا الى كري في
شمال وهانسك في الشمال هذه سته محاور كلها
في في محور واحد اللي هو محور ضخموت
بالاساس ومساعدات قليله جدا جنوب هذا
المحور ليس بالكثير الباقي يقوده اما
مشبحه هي كما شاهدنا في فول هتار الخسائر
الكبيره للتعرضوا لها
المشاه البحريه 155 ومعه بعض الفيلق
الثالث الذي حشد مؤخرا هؤلاء المبتدئين
حشدوا مؤخرا قوه احتياط وحوش مؤخرا
فتقدمات خفيفه للغايه في في كل هذه
المحاور مع بعض التراجعات كذلك فالسؤال
الذي الذي يطرح نفسه الاستراتيجيه التي
يعني تضحي بالجنود من اين ستاتي بقوات
احتياط لو
كلمه الرئيس بوتين وفيها يتعهد بالنصر من
اين سياتي النصر هو الان حتى الان هي
هزيمه حتى الان هي هزيمه روسيه في كافه
المراحل وعدم نصر اوكرانيا يعني اوكرانيا
لم تحرر فيها ولكن روسيا فشلت استراتيجيا
اولا في تغيير نظام وفي الدخول ثانيا حتى
في السيطره على المناطق التي ضمتها سياسيا
خرسون لوهانسك كلهم ليسوا تحت السيطره
الروسيه توجد اجزاء منه
ادركنا الوقت شكرا لك من الدوحه دكتور عمر
عاشور استاذه الدراسات الامنيه والعسكريه
وكذلك لضيفي من عمان فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي
ختام هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
الى اللقاء باذن الله
[موسيقى]